Hello everybody, my name is Markiplier.
And welcome to the video, where I'm going to be reacting to my old videos.
I still got a few days left on my baby face, before my beard BLOOMS gloriously.
So I thought the last thing I'd do would be really poignant.
*elevator music*
To watch some of my older videos,
and kinda look back at the mixture of cringe-y stuff
alongside the stuff that I'm actually legitimately proud of like,
I-I-I-always like to look back because it reminds me of how far I've come.
And also it reminds me of
OH, GOD, WHY DID I DO THAT THING!
OH, THAT WAS ME!? OH GOD!
Join me on this adventure because the first one's a real banger of a video.
I linked this on Twitter just yesterday and that's what got me the idea to do this.
Yeah, I don't know why I made this.
I can't even get my thought process behind it, so I'm just gonna play it you- yeah.
*scarily happy music* (OH HERE IT GOES, HERE IT GOES!) *jumpscare of mark*
*PEEK-A-BOO* I see u
*smiling with still super creepy music*
"HAI! :3
*derp* My names MARKIPLIER
AND I'M HERE TO TEACH YOU
HOW TO  SMASH A BOTTLE  AGAINST YOUR HEAD!
FIRST!!!
EMPTY BOTTLE!
AHHHH... *smirks*
THEN...
SMASH!!
*kills himself with bottle while hitting metal sound effect* ARGGGG!"
( what did I just watch) WHOOOO
Oh bo- Oh boy
Oh boy
Ok, we need to talk about this one because there's a lot of things to go through here.
Ok, so first off
I want to reiterate
This video
if you noticed the 30-second videos that I've been doing nowadays
It's the same mindset that I was doing these videos back then
It's like, I know it's stupid!
I KNOW IT'S STUPID!
I did it knowing that it was dumb
And my god... look at my hair
Uh, I don't know why
I probably stood- I mean I can't exactly complain "Why?"
because if we look back at a video that I did just a few months ago
AHHHHHH
*SMACK*
*whisper-laugh*
*edgy music*
I mean...
The only difference is that it's better made *giggles*
Like literally, I took all the skills that I've learned in the 4 1/2 years I've been doing YouTube
And I've made an equally stupid video
But just in a different way
There's a live stream going on right now!
AND YOU'RE NOT WATCHING IT!
*punches couch repeatedly*
*punching continues*
(Someone's on their time of the month..)
*high pitched voice* Oppa gangnam style! *cringes*
*fights with sheets*
*I BELIEVEEE I CAN SWIMMMMM*
WATCH IT!!!
And that was it
Cause I used to make these stupid videos
Like when we were doing live streams on Twitch
I would make a video on YouTube to tell people I'm live on Twitch
Because like the notification system wasn't very good
And yet, like- I- this is still up here
Like so if someone watched it
Like what's- what the fuck are they looking at?
Like, why is this immortalized?
OK, apparently this is the first vlog I've ever done.
I don't remember if that's true but it's the first vlog in the vlog playlist. So, this is the first time I did a vlog.
I'm not even looking at the camera when I start out.
Hello everybody.
Today
is
my
birthday!
*smiles creepily*
Yes! Yeah!
I'm twenty-three today."
Oh god *laughs softly* "-some celebration.
but I also wanted to take a moment to, you know, thank you guys as I usually do.
I don't thank you guys enough. I don't get it, you know, even though I thank you every s--
the end of every single video.
That's still not enough, because you guys have done a tremendous job of getting my new channel
back on its feet. Let me give you some more statistics."
Oh yeah, I used to talk about the statistics.
Why did I do that?? God, why did I, why, lik- *laughs*
You guys don't care about the numbers behind it! The numbers are meaningless
"*gibberish Mark* -I'm a bit sad that that's so low."
Wait, what does- what am I sad about? *click click*
"Oh, 56 shares.. (Mark's face: *n*) I guess sharing's a different mechanic, but *gibberish*
Bit sad that that's so low, but that's okay.
Um..."*Mark laughs*
WAS I JUST PASSIVELY AGGRESSIVELY BEING LIKE
'BUH! MY SHARES ARE LOW *o* THAT'S OKAY, I GUESS!"
"BUH! WHATEVER! Y'KNOW, IT'S-IT'S- IF YOU GUYS DON'T WANNA SHARE,
IT'S FINE, I GUESS!
I'LL JUST BE OVER HERE IN THE NOT-SHARE CORNER!
FUCKIN OFF!'
"I have a job for you guys if you're interested in doing it, go find a friend, tie them to a chair, bound and gag them!"
*Mark jumps around in excitement*
"Roll them up to your computer and play all my videos *gibberish*-"
I SAID THIS EXACT SAME THING! IN THE- IN THE TUBER SIMULATOR VIDEO!
OH MAN! I TOTALLY FORGOT ABOUT THAT!
IT'S NEVER ENOUGH! I NEED MORE SUBSCRIBERS!
ALL THE TIME! MORE PEOPLE TIED TO CHAIRS!
"Find someone, make them subscribe! Tie 'em to a chair,
sign them up to Youtube, y'know, do everything you can-
I'm just joking, that's- it's fine,
you don't have to do that, but th-"
*Mark laughs* xD
'You don't haaaaave to do that!'
'"You don't gotta do that!'
'But you really need to do that, you tol- it's my birthday, I need it.'
'GIVE IT TO ME. GIVE ME THAT. I WANT IT.'
"And I will SEE YOU in the next video. Bye-bye!
*stares into the distance*"
BYE-BYE! *giggles*
It's so adorable!
*Mark laughs* I mean I'm talking about myself, wha- I'm not adorable, whatever :c Fuck me..
Man, trying new things was always a part of it
because I had no idea what I was doing, like,
I-I had to try new things cause I-I-
like no one was giving me a guide
no one had a guide to be a big Youtuber, and then, like
god, fuck, there it is! Holy shit!
*laughs* This is uh,
I wanted to- oh jeez,
I wanted to have, like a sense of professionalism *laughs*
in my videos, which I don't know why I wanted xD
I didn't want that at all xD
"I also got this
Hello Kitty rainbow tiara thingy
that I found on the street vendor.
*swings axe*
Some poor guy was handing them out, and I chopped him with my axe and took it.
I also have this master the universe noise maker...
*Blows (insert Lenny face)*" Do I ever blink?
Am-Am I ever gonna blink? *Blows again*
I was so nervous, ohh god!
I was so nervous!
"-Action quality on my 'V-LOGS' so *gibberish*"
WHY V- WHOAA!
WAIT A MINUTE!
HOLD ON..
"-on my 'V-LOGS' so *gibberish*
-Action quality on my ""V-LOGS""
-my """"V-LOGS""""
-My """"""V-lOgS""""""
*slow motion* -Accccction quaaaalityyy
*slow motion* onnn my vvv-logss so *gibberish*"
*Mark's sounds of disappointment*
"-quality entertainment!"
*chuckles* Oh, god!
*breathes*
"-Quality entertainment! *Blows*" *Mark giggles*
"Anyway-"
Oh, jeez! *laughs*
Quality entertainment! (x2)
'Cause, when people think of Markiplier, they think of
QUALITY ENTERTAINMENT!
I was so nervous, like unbelievably nervous
because I was like
'This has gotta be good,
it's gotta be nice
Everyones gonna love it <3
Everyone's gonna appreciate it.'
And, like, at the time,
Like, it got a good response
Like, I was, like,
Then I was, like,
'Yeah That's The Way To Do It!
Thats Gooood Yeah!'
I think it was just, like,
'Ah, well, we feel sorry for this
This
Awkward nerd here!
WHATA NURD!!
SHATAP YA NERD!!!'
"All of you beautiful people in there. (Thanks old Mark <3)
We can actually make a difference
If we can unite behind a common goal
And believe that gaming is actually an important part of our world,
is gonna change society in
the years to come!
That's what I believe.
And that's what I'm gonna push.
And that's what I want to be a part of.
And I wanna make you a part of that as well.
So-" Oh man....
I-I had
such high hopes
as a kid.
AS A KID!!??
THAT'S WHEN I WAS 23
*mumbles* when i was 23
YOU KNOW THAT KID 4 YEARS AGO
I still do.
God, I still do.
Like I-I'm so proud of everything that we've done
and I'm so proud of, like, how far we've come...
And we are gonna get back into the monthly livestreams!
That's one of the reasons why Tyler is here now,
because he's also gonna helping me do that.
And we are gonna be doing MONTHLY livestreams.
Right now we've been doing WEEKLY livestreams
as a part of like, you know, uh, just uh, stuff we're doing on Youtube Prime Time.
*inhale* Um
but then AFTER that we're gonna be doing
MONTHLY Charity Livestreams.
We're gonna be- be getting back in that
swing of things
I wanna bring, you know,
Wade and Bob out here again
to be able to apart of it
and you know have like a CENTRAL  camping ground
for this so happen
like I want it again.
And it's like- it's one of those things where you're like,
'OH!
I WANT THAT!'
and then I-I'm like,
I have to go like,
'*slaps face* YOU STUPID PIECE OF SHIT
YOU CAN DO IT!!!!
NOW!!!!!
DO IT!!! Just fucking do it!'
Its like, 'Hell yeah! I'm gonna do it,
So- "I'm-"
Woah, man, what is up with the color balance.
WOAH
"Hello every body" HI "Markiplier here and I just-"
Holy shit
hang on, I gotta go, go back
and do that again
HI
"Hello everybody, Markiplier here"
WHAT THE FUCK
I just wanted to do a quick V-log
to answer some questions-
V-log
V-LOG
*slowed down* "I just wanted to do
a quick V-LOG
to answer some questions
that some" *markigiggles* "people have assembled for me."
I don't know what was up with my lighting.
I-I uh I look like a baked potato. (which you are)
Uh, put a wig on me and maybe i could run for president. (Hah, Trump joke)
But, my god! Blegh.
Oh noh....
Oh nuh....
"HI! My name is Markiplier
and last week a lost a bet to you guys
and I've decided that I'm going to try
TO TWERK" (Mark: No.)
"HAHAHAHAHAHA
*DING*
"Now in order to twerk" (Mark:Oh, god.)
"you need three things" (Mark: Ugh.)
"the right clothes
the right music *snaps*
*funky dance music*
*snaps again*"
Honestly, that was a perfectly acceptable music choice.
"*slaps butt* DAMN
*explosion*
*mark twerks to techno rave music: we are all ashamed*"
I mean honestly it's kinda impressive!
I'm not gonna deny...
Not really, it's not impressive at all.
This is bullshit.
"OH MY GOD
OMG
THIS IS THE STUPIDEST THING I'VE EVER DOOOONE!"
Yeah! It is, yeah. It's
pretty damn stupid, yeah.
Why did I do that?
OH MY GOD!
THAT'S THERE FOREVER!
AHHH!
It's online forever.
AHHH i can never run for political office!
NOT THAT I'D WANT TO.
Because *markigiggles* that exists!
It's gonna be like- Imma be like, on a debate
and someone's just gonna be like,
"WATCH THIS VIDEO OF THIS IDIOT OVER HERE!"
Imma be like, "Yep, ok. I concede, I give up.
Alright, I AM an idiot!
I see that now! It's very clear.
Idiot right *points around the room*
*points to the ceiling* up there, yeah....ok...."
OHHHHH!
MONSTER PUPPET PALS!
Oh, Monster Puppet Pals.
"BLUGH
WHY HASN'T MARK UPLOADED MANY VIDEOS TODAY??
*footsteps*
It's because Youtube is being slooow
and taking forever with long videos!
WHAT!!!!!
Hey, what's that over there??
WHAT'S WHAT OVER W- AHHHH!"
Yeah... "-HI"
NOOOO! NOT THIS AGAIN!
I got a lot of toys.
This is back when I still had a P.O. Box
before everything got WAAY too much
and I wasn't able to handle anything
and I got toys in there.
So, it was, like, a handmade Amnesia Grunt
and a handmade NCP-173.
It's jus- it's super adorable.
And I thought that's w-
I like this video! I'm still happy with this video!
I'm totally okay with this video.
Even though you can see the crest of my hair like a
shark in the water peering up above the screen there.
"Hello everybody! We just hit 800,000 subscribers
which is absolutely amazing.
Thank you guys so much for all your undying support.
You know, this many people has got me thinking about
how far we've come as a channel and just
all the videos that we've done together, you know.
I can remember them just as if they were yesterday
Yesterday, Yesterday, Yesterday, YESTERDAY!
'Oh, no!!
A Slenderman?!
Oh, no! The Amnesia monster?!
Oh, no! It's SCP-173, from SCP: Containment Breach!
Oh, NO! TWERKING!!
AAAAAHHHHHH!!!!!!!' "
*laughing* I just-!
"Yesterday, yesterday, YESTERDAY,"
Oh, geez. Oh, geez.
"Yesterday!
Those kinda sucked!
I don't know why you've stuck with me for this long, but
THANKS! *DING* "
A least I was some sort of self aw-
"-you guys are awesome."
Oh, hi.
"Could'nt do this without 'cha! So thanks a million!
Or should I say, 800,000!
Hahahahaha! *distorted* HAAHAHAHAHAHA!"
*giggling* Jesus Chr-
Chriminy Chri- OHHH, THIS IS BACK WHEN I TRIED TO BE MANLY!
Oh, GOD! WHY IS THIS NEXT IN THE QUEUE?!
WHY DO THEY KNOW ME SO WELL?!
" *unintelligable* "
*giggling* What am I doing?
"Just me and my brother could play together and it was better than any toy ever made."
What am I doing?!
What a-? Why? Why.
" *manly scream* "
*giggling* Oh, Jesus.
" *unintelligable* asks, if I'm so manly,
how was pole dancing? "
Ohh, yeahh!
" Pole dancing requires more muscle strength and coordination than you can possibly imagine. "
That's true! It's hard as hell!
Yeah.
I wanna do pole dancing again.
I wanna do another video. I'm probably gonna do it with Tyler.
Maybe Jack....
" *explosion* How do you shave in the morning?
Well! I just get in a fight with a mountain lion and let it claw it off my face.
*strokes hammer*
*explosion* "
*laughing* I can't watch this!
Ohhh, why did I do this?
Hoooly shit. Okay, so...
*laughs*
I made this video...
because I wanted to be *whispers* creepy!
And I wanted to make a creeepy video.
So, if you want to know where Darkiplier came from
It started after this video.
" *creepy sounds* "
*gasp*
*mocking shock* Oh no!
" *melty face jumpscare* "
Like, this is- *devolves into laughter*
I thought that...
THAT *points*
Was scary! *laughing*
So, you can see...
Uhh... *Mark not impressed with his past self*
And then, uh, after it came this one.
Which is called "Don't Move".
The other one was called "Don't Blink", this one's called "Don't Move".
And, uh...
I don't know, I just found a bunch of bullshit
horror soundtracks and stitched 'em all together.
And then- Oh, no! WHO'S IN THE BACKGROUND!
SOMEONE!
And then, like, some animal roars and stuff like that and...
I don't know!
Is ZAt- Oh, iss so SCARY!
AAH! I SMILED!
AHH, SCARE- only SCARY people smile!
Oh, no I'm NOT smiling...!
Maybe, it was all an illusion....
Yeah, so that's, like, it's just a fascinating, like,
look back into what I've done.
And there's- Ohhhh, BOOP, SUPER JUICE?!
"Oh, what's this? BOOP, Super Juice!
BOOP, Super Juice!
BOOP, Super Juice!"
Yeah, and this goes on for- "Super Juice!" ten minutes.
"Super Juice!"
I uploaded this.
I wasted everybody's time and I don't regret a DAMN THING!!
RÖKNING FÖRBJUDEN!
RÖKNING-!
"RAR Rar Rarar Rawr!" *giggling*
"Rar Rarar Rawr!
Rar Rarar Rawr!" *Mark enjoying himself too much*
Rar Rarar Rawr!
Rar Rarar Rawr!" Awww, shit.
One more video...
"The Slender Man!"
The Fall of Slenderman!
"Once, the most feared-"
The first sketch I EVER did!
"Now-"
The first sketch I EVER did and
literally, like, the birth of Warfstache.
I think that was out of focus.
"Sooooo, Slenderman, the former triumpherant of terror,
the epitome of eeeevil!
reduced to-"
Oh man, it's like,
"with an ill-fitting suit and a ridiculous mustache...."
It's just, like, it's hilarious
'cause it's, like, added value that I did this in
my mom's living room.
I didn't know how to film correctly
and we had to cut in between two different ones!
BUT, I LOVE IT!
OHHH, I LOVE IT!!
AHHH, I LOVE IT!!
I love it, I love it, I love it!
It's so good!!
"Warfstache *unintelligable* "
Oh, it was, like, trial and error to get to this point
and, of course, Wade was very patient in helping me
in doing this shit.
Like, this- *laughing* What the fuck is this?
He's just, he's just creepin' up behind me.
"And also, don't move to Jamaica
and wear a ridiculous wig.
*bleep* off, Slendy!
Warstache don't take no *bleep* from nobody."
And, like, the most amazing thing is like,
Aw, man. And this is the first time I ever did, like, an outro
with an annotation on it and it had bloopers and everything.
And, like, I was really proud of it!
AND I STILL AM! I'M STILL PROUD OF THIS!
I LOVE THIS THING!!
No one can tell me that this is bad,
because I love it and it had HEART and SOUL!
And, man, it was the birth of Warfstache.
And, good GOD
I felt so good after I made that.
I watched this after I made it
and still, to this day, like, I watch it every once in a while.
I've watched it probably, like,
Oh, fifty or sixty times.
I'm not even exaggerating, I watched it over and over.
You can ask Wade.
I watched it over and over and over again. And I just
I looked at every detail of it.
And I love it so much
'cause it represents everything I've wanted to do.
And everything that I HAVE DONE!
AAHH! Okay, anyway, sorry,
I'm getting super nostalgic right now.
I love trying new things.
I love doing new things, I love branching out,
I love surprising you guys
with all sorts of random, weird videos.
Even if it means I just slap on a stupid pink mustache
in my American Eagle shirt and
like, jeans and a chair that's OBVIOUSLY MY MOM'S!
Oh, it's so good.
Like, I love these things, I love doing these things.
I love, like, I love seeing all these,
like, pieces of history, pieces of my history
and people's.... Like, I-I.. i-it's great!
I-it's great to me. And it's great to look back,
because it makes me remember, like,
where I 've come from and the things that have worked
and the things that haven't worked.
And it makes me proud that I've, like,
I've kept all that up on my channel and it's just like,
it's my legacy, it's where I've come from.
It's how I learned to be who I am today.
And it's like, in five years, I'm gonna look
back at these videos and be like, 'Oh, my gosh!
I can see me learning to be the person I wanna be then!'
And it's like, just, stepping stones to something bigger
and I love it.
Anyway.
This, uh- Like I said, this was a rollercoaster of emotions
and it always is when I look back at my videos, but
we hit some of the more, eugh, awkward ones
than I would have normally done, but still,
it's good to see those, too, because it's good to see, like,
just, like, that- that little sense of immaturity is still
burning bright in my heart, so
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
Let me know what you thought of this
down in the comments below.
I hope you enjoyed it. I certainly did.
And, if you want to see something else like this,
I can review, like, the year of 2013 and 14,
because this was mostly 2012 and 2013.
And it's still just as awkward, 2013 and 2014, so
there's a lot more cool stuff out there, so
Thank you everybody so much for watching.
And as ALWAYS, I will see YOU
in the next video!
Buh BYE!